burg and now it's time for how to be a
pirate coming from dead scores Pub bill
some call me my real name self and then
you gotta teach a hall to be a pilot
today on the special DVD episode we're
gonna be talking about hats now a lot of
beginners always ask what kind of had to
find me as a pirate well something that
you may not know is that there's
actually a cool dance in fact many
pirates collect hats from the series of
people that they slaughtered in the past
missing is there a cure for what's wrong
with you dog take that house off your
sister a very intelligent either 1+2 way
she can't even spell like you now I know
what a lot of your thinking laughable
bill do you collect a lot of hats and
every one of them has a story about a
person isolate for example high gathered
this one after slaughtering the crew of
the SS birthday cake what kind
ridiculous name is that they claim up
they were there for some kids birthday
party but they into the bully mom if it
was a birthday party where all the
children crying he's in the night mr.
Bruhl I'll pay for your funeral if you
just dog said something intelligent
there I mean that he's an idiot man so
stupid he thought that Indian girl was
making fun M night Shyamalan by that I
got more hats to show ya
less holocaust after slaughtering a
mariachi band in France I never knew
Mexicans were French I'm sure they have
a story but I didn't wanna tell it I
read by Monsieur Kaka this after
slaughtering the prison they mr. penny
bites only present I've ever seen to
fight with a thimble next one I got from
an especially strange pirate he had a
great white beard and kept sayin yo ho
ho except he can't confuse him the first
yield for hallways quite nuts he kept
saying he was working for this army of
salvation some army olia was a bell that
doesn't make a very hungry welcome
against the sword means I killed them if
anyone's on about this crazy connection
between him and baby Jesus all the crazy
is that night mister dear circus is down
the street
had an asset closely freeloader Mansell
easy uses a wheelchair on an escalator
that's what I got left are slaughtering
an army of the so called anime nerds
I wouldn't mind except the guy was
wearing this this one night cap after
spending the night with the Cowboys of
Brokeback Mountain let's never talk
about again this one I gather the
college dorm pretty drunk don't remember
this was from a transvestite yes some
bum off the street yet don't want at all
and that's much there are some hats
collection it is mighty Apple do say so
myself
isn't it like mr. far I'm tired can you
just install yourself for me yes then
the belly of a cannibal yeah Jacques
that's entirely on the level either
that's a crazy it's a food was a pussy
me but in reality they look for I even
enjoy if I say that blood the bear Joe
is so cool but he creative Antarctic
they see the littles blood the bear job
who blessed you have no with the ability
to get ladies it was Bob your Joe who
first laid Dracula that maybe allowed
them to resurrect himself just so others
do the same
who let the beer Joel once got in a
fight with Edward from Twilight
and now his body is being sold in every
jewelry store on the Wow they say that
dr. Frankenstein once tried to build
another bloody beer Joe himself but all
he turned out creating what the coverage
her name she is no cap they say that
when Mighty Thor was building his hammer
that he used blood their jaw sword as a
reference they see that's when bored the
beer Joel wants to fight up a handicap
he puts on two IEP because of one I
would still be unfair blood the beer
Joel's pisses soulmate it I'm drinking
it right - no I'm sure they see that the
blood the beer Joel wanna get out of
hell free card but by putting poker with
God they say that would be a joke and oh
one more watch five he was bar blood the
beer Joe saw somebody's parents
destroyed two hundred men simply by
sneeze
what was the parents name I don't know
strange thing to ask so let's all raise
a glass double up the bear job he may
not be God holy yes yes gentlemen that
sign for Hull to be a pilot see us this
war is how to be a pirate
the greatest show that ever er